muchos dicen que la escuela no les está
enseñando a los chicos a pensar yo creo
que es mucho peor les estamos enseñando
a no pensar
yo soy investigaron educación y una de
mis pasatiempos es recorrer escuelas y
recoger todas las preguntas que aparecen
en los pizarrones me encantan los
pizarrones porque son como una manera de
meterme como una espía un ratito lo que
pasa en el aula son una gran ventana lo
que está pasando yo me dedico a
investigar cómo se enseñan las ciencias
naturales en las escuelas desde el
jardín de infantes a la universidad y
pensar maneras de mejorar eso y en
general me encuentro con todas preguntas
muy parecidas todas cortadas por la
misma tijera les cuento algunas de paso
vean si se la saben
qué es una célula cuáles son sus partes
si van bien
qué es la nutrición que se diferencia de
la alimentación
qué tipos de formas puede tomar la
energía
estas capas tiene el planeta tierra con
esta los mato que dice la primera ley de
newton
y esta última pongo plata apuesto a que
todo el mundo algunas la estudió en la
escuela y que muy poquitos la podrían
responder hoy cuáles son las fases de la
mitosis
ahorrar
que tienen en común todas estas
preguntas son preguntas prácticas son
preguntas que se responden con un dato
con un hecho con una definición son
preguntas cuya respuesta busco en un
libro la copio aunque no lo haya
entendido del todo me lo olvido mañana
sí quiero
está mal que estén estas preguntas en
los pizarrones
yo no creo que esté mal de hecho está
bien queremos que los chicos salgan de
la escuela sabiendo que es una célula
sabiendo que distintas formas puede
adoptar la energía
el problema no es que estas preguntas
estén en los pizarrones el problema es
que estas son las únicas preguntas que
están en nuestros pizarrones les voy a
mostrar un ejemplo de mi pizarrón
favorito miren el extremo ya yo les leo
está chiquito dice con ayuda del libro
además respondan el siguiente
cuestionario pregunta a las células
intervienen en el proceso de crecimiento
es la respuesta a esa pregunta y sí
señor
pregunta ve las células se reproducen
y sí también
y si vamos a la formación docente el
escenario es bastante parecido hace dos
años hicimos una investigación en un
instituto de formación de profesores muy
prestigiosos del norte de argentina y
fuimos a ver qué preguntas les hacían en
los exámenes finales los profesores a
sus alumnos que van a ser a su vez
futuros docentes las clasificamos y
encontramos algo tremendo el 71% de esas
preguntas eran preguntas prácticas y de
esas buena parte a preguntas
terminológica las preguntas que se
responden con una palabrita con un
término técnico les cuento un ejemplo
para que se den una idea de qué se trata
este es un diálogo entre el profesor que
está tomando examen y el alumno que está
rindiendo y el alumno le dijo la palabra
a donar pero profesor quería la palabra
transferir están hablando de un proceso
que se llama transferencia de electrones
algo que como todos se acuerdan ocurre
en la mitocondria
y entonces el profesor le dice no es
donar cuál es la palabra correcta
el silencio de radio del otro lado a ver
yo te voy a ayudar imagínate que yo
estoy en misiones tengo un hijo en
corrientes y necesita plata que hago le
envío dicen alumnos la tengo si si le
envío pero como se llama eso en el banco
trans y un seguro como docente que ya no
sabe qué más hacer para que te digan la
respuesta correcta ya con el cuerpo no
los tenés que ayudar trans transportó
dice el alumno no lo quiere matar no no
le transfiero no es lo mismo donar que
transferir es muy importante que sepas
bien las palabras
pero lo más interesante de esta
investigación es que cuando
entrevistamos a estos mismos profesores
les preguntamos cuál era el sentido de
lo que querían enseñar que querían
lograr con sus alumnos con estos futuros
profesores todos coincidieron en lo
mismo queremos enseñarles a ser curiosos
queremos enseñarles a entender el mundo
queremos enseñarles a ser críticos
y sin embargo aún con las mejores
intenciones nuestras aulas tanto en la
escuela como en la formación docente
están llenas de conocimiento fáctico de
conocimiento inerte
y esto es grave no solo porque nos
estamos perdiendo la chance de enseñar
cosas mucho más importantes más
interesantes es más grave aún porque
después de años y años y tantos años que
los chicos se pasan en la escuela los
chicos aprenden sí pero que aprenden
aprende que aprender es repetir incluso
sin entender del todo que aprenden a
recitar y aprenden que aprender es una
actividad es apasionada algo que hacemos
para otros no para nosotros mismos
y entonces qué
como cambiamos esta situación tal vez la
pregunta sea por dónde empezar
obviamente estamos ante un escenario muy
complejo tiene muchas causas algunas de
las causas son sumamente profundas
pero una de las cosas que aprendimos en
estos años de trabajar mucho con
escuelas es que una de las claves está
justamente en ponerle el foco a las
preguntas en transformar esas preguntas
prácticas las preguntas muertas en
preguntas para pensar
en casos en desafíos en problemas que
presenten cuestiones intrigantes que no
le den ganas de responder
les voy a contar dos ejemplos de cómo
sería los ejemplos que usamos mucho con
las escuelas el primer ejemplo es una
pregunta clásica de la escuela primaria
pregunta fáctica si las hay cuáles son
las características de los seres vivos y
ahí todos aprendemos aprendimos a
repetir como loros a ver voy a ver si me
ayudan los seres vivos nacen crecen se
reproducen y finalmente muy bien todos
han ido a la escuela acá genial
esto lo dicen los libros de primer grado
cuando los chicos son más grandes les
decimos medio que lo mismo solo que
agregamos un par de viñetas más por
ejemplo los seres vivos tienen células
respiran responden al medio
miren cómo sería una pregunta para
pensar sobre esta misma idea de que los
seres vivos tienen ciertas
características en común que los definen
resulta que ayer estaba cocinando pan en
casa estaba cocinando y de repente me di
cuenta que pucha le faltaba la levadura
y me fue súper a comprar levadura nueva
agarre de la heladera
estaba en la cola para pagar una señora
me miró y me dijo me dio en secreto me
dijo hey cuidarla mucho a esta levadura
no se te vaya a morir
mira que la levadura es un ser vivo
diseño de discúlpeme usted tiene algún
problema como esta levadura esta pasta
que tengo acá va a ser un ser vivo esto
no se parece a ningún ser vivo que yo
conozca y me fui
pague primero
y mientras iba caminando a casa me quedé
pensando
si la señora tuviera razón
cómo podría yo averiguar si esta
levadura es o no es un ser vivo
fíjense como ahora si los seres vivos
nacen crecen se reproducen y mueren no
sirve más no alcanza para responder esta
pregunta ahora hay que pensar
y entonces sí con un sentido los chicos
estudian que los seres vivos tienen
ciertas características en común y junto
con la maestra les buscan la vuelta para
averiguar se la levadura los cumple o no
los cumple por ejemplo seres vivos se
reproducen y la levadura
una manera de averiguarlo es poner un
poco de levadura en un pan húmedo
esperar unos días y aparece levadura
nueva vamos bien
los seres vivos tienen células y la
levadura tiene ese plazo no la manera de
averiguarlo es poner un poquito de
levadura bajo el microscopio se ven un
montón de células dando vueltas las pudo
matar a la levadura así es un ser vivo
una manera de averiguarlo es poner
levadura hervir un ratito volver a
ponerlo en pan y ver que ya no hay más
levadura nueva
la pregunta ya no es un callejón sin
salida es una puerta de entrada para
aprender
les cuento el segundo ejemplo cuando los
chicos estudian sobre el sonido una
pregunta fáctica clásica es cómo se
propaga el sonido y los chicos aprenden
lo que cuenta este manual de acá que los
sonidos se propagan por un medio de ese
medio puede ser líquido sólido gas ese
medio tiene que vibrar el sonido se
probaba en forma de ondas en distintos
medios se propaga a distintas
velocidades en el vacío no hay sonido
copian lo cuentan en una prueba algunos
lo entienden más menos fin de la
cuestión a otra cosa mariposa
miren cómo sería una pregunta para
pensar sobre esta misma idea de que el
sonido tiene que viajar por un medio que
vibra y para esto tiene que hacer un
minuto de memoria volver a su infancia
alguna vez jugaron con teléfonos caseros
seguro que si no son si no jugaron si
una pieza carísima sofisticadísima de
tecnología algo como esto si no fueron
nunca este es el momento cuando vuelvo
en hoy a sus casos es muy divertido es
muy adictivo y de hecho eso fue lo que
les pasó
agustín ya violeta dos hermanos que
habían estado toda la tarde en el patio
de su casa jugando con teléfonos caseros
y de tanto jugar y jugar o algo que les
llamó la atención
el teléfono para andar siempre tenía que
estar con el hilo bien estirado si tiene
estado colgando no funcionaba más
y se pusieron a discutir por qué estaría
pasando eso y agustín decía yo se viole
el rey día lo que pasa es que si el hilo
está colgando está flojo no tiembla y
por eso no llega el sonido pero violeta
no estaba para nada de acuerdo nada que
ver a agus
lo que pasa es otra cosa cuando el
sonido va por el hilo que está flojo
llega abajo y se cae al piso y no puede
volver a subir
y así se quedaron discutiendo
o podemos hacer para saber quién de los
dos hermanos tiene razón
y de nuevo la pregunta abre el camino
para aprender y para explorar esta
pregunta alarme después de trabajar
mucho con chicos de primaria con
teléfonos caseros y siempre pasaba algo
parecido a lo que les pasó a agustín y
violeta muchos de los chicos les diría
la mitad de la clase siempre estaban
convencidos de que el sonido se caía al
piso y no podía volver a subir
y entonces así los chicos en grupos se
tienen que romper la cabeza para buscar
una manera de ver quién de los dos
hermanos tiene razón
y siempre siempre algunos de los grupos
llegan a una solución que es simple pero
brillante poner el teléfono en posición
vertical parado con el hijo con el hilo
bien tirante hablar desde abajo y
escuchar desde arriba si violeta tiene
razón y el sonido no puede trepar qué va
a pasar no se va a escuchar nada si en
cambio el que tiene razón es agustín va
a pasar lo contrario se va a escuchar
fenómeno
lo más lindo de estas preguntas para
pensar creo yo es que los chicos no sólo
aprenden ideas conceptos importantes
sobre cómo funciona el sonido los seres
vivos o el tema que fuera aprenden
capacidades de razonamiento que les van
a acompañar toda la vida aprenden a
debatir aprenden el resolver problemas
junto con otros aprenden a analizar
datos aprenden a discernir entre
distintas explicaciones aprenden a
pensar
pero esta idea de las preguntas para
pensar no es nueva en educación
sin embargo estamos lejos muy muy lejos
de que esto sea una realidad en todas
las escuelas pero la gran noticia es que
cuando eso pasa los resultados son
maravillosos les quiero mostrar unos
son los resultados de un programa que
venimos llevando a cabo desde el año
2007 un programa que se llama escuelas
del bicentenario por el que pasaron más
de 130 escuelas públicas de la franja
más pobre de toda la argentina
al principio del programa les tomamos
una prueba a los chicos todos con
preguntas para pensar que fue horrible
muy poquitos de los chicos podían
responderlas
después de cuatro años de trabajar con
cada escuela con los maestros y los
directores reformulando cada uno de los
temas de todo el programa con preguntas
para pensar los resultados fueron
diametralmente opuestos maravillosamente
mejores ahora sí casi todos los chicos
podían responder estas preguntas y lo
más lindo es que decían que eran rey
fáciles no eran nada fáciles eran revise
y si de eso que pasa es que habían
estado trabajando así con sus maestros
todo el año
por eso cuando yo miro estos datos
siento que tenemos entre manos una gran
oportunidad pero también un gran deber
porque lo que nos dicen estos datos es
que el cambio es posible no que fácil no
es nada fácil
es difícil requiere un montón de
esfuerzo requiere estrategia requiere
hacer las cosas bien pero es posible y
es posible en escuelas reales
potenciando los maestros y profesores
que tenemos hoy en el sistema educativo
es posible con los chicos que tenemos
hoy en la escuela y es posible en
tiempos razonables
nuestras escuelas hoy están enseñando a
no pensar pero tenemos entre manos la
chance y también la urgencia creo yo de
ayudar a los chicos a reconectarse con
el sentido y con el disfrute de su
aprendizaje
tenemos las escuelas de preguntas para
pensar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]